there we go so this is it right this is
our tech preview build we're looking at
it right now live
yep this is the essentially the menu
that you're gonna hit as soon as you
boot up so um you can see like the
multiplayer academy options there if you
hit
start you can get into our main settings
and there's a few settings i think we
want to we want to show let's take a
look i mean
no i i like settings no one's ever seen
these settings in detail before so we'll
just we'll kind of take a look here so
um we want to make sure obviously
players understand and like first thing
you should do if you're going to be in
the tech preview this week and probably
just kind of get acclimated
tweak your settings to your liking just
make sure that things are sort of the
way you want them if you will so
i think you know i'll just quickly
scroll through i'm not going to speak to
every one of these i think we'll be here
all afternoon but
i think you're going to find a lot of um
sort of what you'd expect to find
in some regards you know hold the sprint
if i want to do that i can kind of
really dial in my sensitivity and all
that
i'm pretty casual so i kind of tend to
just run default in a lot of cases i'm
not afraid to admit that
yeah i think that i've never gotten into
all the zoom sensitivity settings but
i'm just worried that i would get myself
into a state where i would just never
land a shot again or who knows maybe i
would suddenly sort of evolve to the
next level
um now keyboard and mouse players uh on
pc
uh and also i believe console now
supports uh pc
mouse and keyboard as well excuse me um
couple things here they might want to
look at that's pretty interesting if we
can get down
to it is the fact that you know triple
keybinds you can you have a lot of
flexibility here and how you want to set
up your keys
i want to give a shout out you know as
all the work that happened over the last
couple years to update mcc and bring
that to pc
and all the fantastic work by the pub
team you know being able to have triple
keybinds was
super important to the pc community that
was great feedback that we heard and
that's a good example of just one
of taking those learnings and kind of
that experience and bringing it over to
the infinite side
yeah i think we owe a great debt to all
the work that mcc and the publishing
team has done
with diving in like feet first into the
pc environment
and getting us ready for this you know
i'll hover on this one for a minute
because i'm pretty sure i haven't been
able to do this before in the game have
i been able to actually just straight up
drop my weapon for a teammate before
nothing i know of and honestly it's been
it's been quite fun to use
uh especially when you're playing with
like some less experienced players
you can just secure rockets for them and
then hand it over to them
you know they get to play around with a
power weapon that they might not
normally have gotten
so dare we say maybe this is the end of
betraying your teammates to take sniper
yeah now you just got to extort them i
guess possibly cool so a whole bunch of
stuff here
you know this is something else that we
i think was mentioned in one of our
employee spotlight blogs but
um marking this is also a new element
to halo games yeah and i've actually
been really happy with the marking
system
so if you're on pc it is super easy just
to mock everyone you see and the game
rewards you for you actually get points
you get a mark assist if someone kills
someone who you've marked
and stacks with your normal assist
points and i believe there's a medal you
can earn
there is mocking enough people who get
killed
so i'll just kind of scroll through here
quickly so we don't totally get
inundated in settings but it just goes
on and on and on so let me go over here
to video as well
something else i just kind of want to
point out which by the way i do not that
is
criminal for me to be on a fov of only
70 but you know we heard i think this
has always been something halo fans have
wanted
we we know and everyone knows the fov
really does have a dynamic impact on
your experience
in terms of not only just your vision
but the sensation of movement and speed
all those things are greatly impacted so
pretty awesome to me that on day one we
already have a field of view slider and
this is going to be available on
i think on multiple platforms it's not a
pc only feature that's correct yeah
i mean what's your preference i kind of
generally like to kick it up here maybe
in the 90 to 100 range i mean we can go
what all the way up to 120 if we really
wanted to
yeah i usually like to kick it in 95 to
100. all right well
i'll split the difference we'll go 95
there but yeah just kind of go through
here
lots of different nuanced graphical
settings to really allow people to
custom tailor based on
you know their own personal preferences
what's most important to them on their
pc hardware
um if i didn't mention that if it's not
clear we are playing on pc here
currently so
um you know you will not have the full
breadth of all these options necessarily
on every platform
but clearly for pc it makes the most
sense i thought this is pretty cool too
being able to sort of opt in or opt out
of something that we call speed lines so
when you're sprinting in the game we
have some cool visual effects that help
sort of really convey that sense of
increased speed but if i don't like it i
can just turn it off yeah i think the
the fact that we've got so many settings
that are tailored so that you can fully
immerse yourself
or if you're looking for a stripped down
experience if you don't want that
you can turn it off same thing goes of
course lots of audio customization here
um i want to make sure people are aware
of like things like subtitles you can
turn those off and on if you want to
i did want to call this out as well i
know you and i were talking earlier
about this but
just a little bit of a public service
announcement for anyone playing this
weekend in the tech preview
by default currently in this build your
mic is just set to full open full hot
so some people might like that some
people may not personally i was kind of
caught by surprise when i was saying a
bunch of stuff in the game and i thought
it was private
so i just wanted to pass that my
learning's on to you so no one gets kind
of caught and maybe in a precarious
situation there
um so yeah a lot of different options
here including spartan chatter we'll
hear a little bit more of that
when we roll some more footage um and
then the last thing i thought would be
kind of cool to really point out we've
talked about this a little bit briefly
in some of our blogs but we have this
new system that we're calling friend
info right which
in order to really support and embrace
our goals and our aspirations about
leaning more into player expression and
having a lot more cool ways to customize
your own spartan and your own spartan
journey
it just didn't really work anymore to
force everyone into a
default red or blue model right right
and and so by default we have red and
blue outlines
but for accessibility purposes we know
the various people can't see
in certain shades so we've got a wide
array of colors that you can choose for
both enemies
and friends and you can also customize
the focus in your fire team
to be another unique color yeah it's it
is really flexible really cool i also
personally being able like being able to
sort of
if i want to go old school and display a
full gamer tag above someone's head i
could do that
also helps me sometimes when i'm
personally just trying to register a
friend from foe
um and then you know i should call this
out you'll see this in the in the ui
menu here the theater will not be
included in the tech preview so we won't
have that experience the theater is
coming back though so
um and you know event timeline is a
brand new feature we'll talk a little
bit more about that later but
you could probably surmise what that
might mean in the context of the theater
um and this is pretty crazy too weapon
offset so
people want to be able to move that
stuff around i guess yeah
i know i know i know people who like to
get uh that's like different
guess you know one of the gamepl themes
here is just trying to give players as
many
options as possible to really dial in
the experience to suit their personal
tastes right yeah i mean
it is just a set of menus but i'm really
looking forward to hearing people think
of these settings
and the things that they can put
together to customize it to
exactly how they want to be i want halo
to be like the comfiest chair in your
house
i like that all right so let's back out
of the settings something else i think
we want to point out to participants in
the tech previews to keep an eye on this
weekend
the news feed wow this is like next gen
news
no seriously um this is just good to
keep an eye on if you're playing in the
tech preview we will probably use this
to convey
updates over the course of the flight
critical information
if the playlist experience evolves we'll
let people know through here right
and i think sam you wanted to
specifically call this one out in
particular right
yeah so we've got a notification for
people on pc especially if you're using
the amd gpu
you're going to want to make sure you
update to the latest driver it is a
significant performance increase
for pc users on amd gpus so please make
sure you do that and make sure you check
out the news for
that kind of attention announcement
awesome well sam
i think that's all i got for you today
any final parting words or thoughts
before we jump over and dig into some
customization
no i want to see the customization too
thanks for having me cool thank you sam
we'll be right back in just a moment
going to be joined by jerry hook here
we're going to talk about
all the things you can do to customize
your spartan in the tech preview be
right back in just a moment